Economists tend to focus on things
that can be measured.
Dignity is hard to measure.
A sense of self is hard to measure.
Belonging is hard to measure.
A feeling of transcendence is hard
to measure.
Mattering, that
you are important, that people
look to you.
They're about the life well lived.
And they're not about getting the
most out of your money.
They're not about what the interest
rates are next week.
And economists truthfully have
virtually nothing to say about these
things.
Economist Russ Roberts is well known
for his extraordinary gift at
finding creative ways of
communicating the power of free
market capitalism to the general
public.
Bread eaters will rejoice when
they see that every bakery
is filled with so much choice.
He's the host of the wildly
successful podcast Econ Talk,
which has been cranking out weekly
episodes since 2006.
I hope our listeners find it
fascinating, too.
If you do find this interesting,
please send an email to me.
Russell Roberts.
Is the author of two novels.
The Invisible Heart and Economic
Romance is one of those classic
boy meets girl stories.
But in this case, the boy is an
economist. So it's kind of
a handicap that evokes all
the classic love stories of the past
involving economists.
I can't think of any either.
And along with filmmaker John
Coppola, he created the blockbuster
Keynes Hayek rap videos.
We've been going back and forth for
a century.
I want to steer markets.
I want them set free.
There's a boom and bust cycle.
And good reason to fear it.
I've made my case.
Freddie H. Listen up.
Can you hear it?
More recently, his interest has
turned to the fundamental inadequacy
of his chosen discipline to
comprehend what matters most to
people. Robert's new book is called
Wild Problems, and it deals
with the decisions that define us.
Whether to marry, whether to have
kids. What kind of work to pursue?
He says these are the sorts of
central questions that can't
be figured out with economic
modeling and cost-benefit analysis.
Reason talked with
the 68-year-old Roberts about how he makes sense of a world that is richer than ever in material resources and yet suffers increasing numbers of deaths of despair. We discuss his own life from earning a Ph.D. in economics at the University of Chicago in the 1970s to starting econ talk to becoming president of a private liberal arts college in Israel, to the central role that religion plays in his life.
Russ Roberts, thanks for talking to
Reason.
Great to see you again, Nick.
It's been a long time.
It has been.
But the new book is Wild
Problems.
Give me the elevator pitch.
So there are elevator pitches that
there are a number of aspects of our
lives, big decisions we face
that we'd like to have data
and evidence and make a rational,
logical decision about them.
These are decisions like whether
they have children, whether to
marry, who to marry, what career to
pursue.
And there's not that many
pieces of evidence.
And if I may in the case of Francis
Bacon, who comes up whether
to marry a child.
Yeah.
Am I wrong?
Yeah. I learned a little too much
about Francis Bacon in this book.
This is a man who said, if you
marry, you became a hostage
to fortune.
And by fortune, he did not mean
riches.
He meant the randomness of life.
Luck. Good luck.
Bad luck. So he said, Why don't you
marry? You're a hostage to fortune.
He married late in life and he
well.
He was late in life.
She was 45.
She is 14 plus
or minus six months, right?
But he saw her.
But he saw her, he had his eye on
her when she was 11.
They didn't have the best
relationship, which.
Is the Enlightenment's version
of Georgy Girl or something?
It's just it's a very disturbing
scenario.
It's a British film, right?
It is a British film.
Yeah. With that Sr. James Mason.
Yeah,
well, I Francis Bacon is also
we're getting ahead of ourselves as
always, but he's one of Hayek's
enemies, so he's like an
epistemological enemy of Friedrich
Hayek. Who thought that Bacon
kind of ushered in all that was
wrong about enlightenment, thinking
and scientism, and whatnot?
But to come back while
problems are problems that
that resists measurement.
Yes. And so talk about
and you do spend a lot of time early
on talking about like, okay, how,
you know, how do you make a decision
whether or not to get married and
Charles Darwin even more than Bacon
is kind of your you know, one of the
one of the textbook cases you work
through.
Yeah. Talk a little bit about that
and how that kind of explains the
larger set of issues that you're
trying to get at with Wild Problems.
So I used Darwin as an example
because I think most people would
agree he is perhaps the greatest
scientist of all time.
Okay, maybe second or third if
you're a skeptic about that, but
he's clearly a rational person.
And I use a number of scientists
and analytical thinkers and
academics who struggle.
With these kind of decisions that
we're talking about because they're
used to using analytical thinking
in the rest of their life.
But when it comes to these kind of
decisions, they're kind of
unmoored at sea.
And so Darwin tries to do what
most economists or other people
would say is rational.
And you'll get this advice all the
time make a pro-con list,
make a list of the costs of the
benefits, and weigh them in
and see what's the right choice.
And he does that.
He makes a list.
It's embarrassing.
He compares horribly embarrassing.
He says coming home to a wife
would be better than a dog, at
least.
Kind of a low bar for
a spouse.